hi I'm Hannah I am your friendly
neighborhood wine mom oh hi didn't see
you there if you are like me you believe
that one glass of wine at 8:00 p.m.
makes you a better mom so pour yourself
one and let's talk about stuff the best
part is you don't even have to have kids
to be a wine mom we're going to have
some Chardonnay that is the unofficial
official wine of all wine home early now
I'm ready
here's why I'm drinking tonight my son
is obsessed with the movie that's out
right now called BFG but somehow in his
four-year-old brain it's getting all
scrambled and my sister-in-law finally
took him to see it on Sunday come Monday
I find out that he's telling everyone oh
my aunt you took me to see CPS over the
weekend and for those of you who don't
know what CPS stands for it is Child
Protective Services so now I have
everybody thinking that my sister-in-law
is taking my son to see Child Protective
Services because I am a terrible mother
so let's talk about the best and worst
things about having kids kids are the
most beautiful creatures on the planet
my kids are the most wonderful humans
I've ever met in my life that being said
the first board that I think about when
art so that being said the first word
that comes to mind when I think about
parenting is [ __ ] the first five or so
years of your life you're being [ __ ] on
literally oh the first five or so years
of their life you're being [ __ ] on
literally and then from there on out you
get [ __ ] on emotionally I have a four
year old and a one year old so I'm
halfway through wiping too but then when
it finally comes time to wipe your own
butt you don't even get to do that alone
my four year old likes to sit and watch
me actually both of them like to sit and
watch me and then when I say I'd like
some privacy my four year old will go oh
okay
he'll shoo the one-year-old out close
the door and sit back down okay dude
whatever that [ __ ] is not the only
bodily fluid that comes out of these
kids there's just so much wetness like
my kids think that I want them to hand
me their boogers
okay
then when they vomit it's like they go
out of their way to vomit on something
important so my son will run out onto
the couch to vomit on this fabric couch
you were in the bathroom
why how but even when they're doing that
I'm proud of them even when they puke
everywhere and I'm cleaning this up I'm
like needy and vomit knee-deep in vomit
I'm like I am proud of you because I see
that you ate your whole dinner I see
broccoli in here you ate some veggies
nice so next I can can't be drunk
because it's just one glass I'm not even
done so just this is just me next so
when you have kids you become accustomed
to constant noise it's like you kind of
train yourself to zone it out once you
finally get your silence it's terrifying
something terrible is happening there's
poop on the walls for sure there's
crayon on something someone's eating my
lipstick so one time it was silent and
my son was in the bathroom dunking the
bath towels into the toilet and then
sucking on them why would you do that
are you thirsty does it taste good is
there something I'm missing about this
toilet water so you can't win you
finally get your silence and it's all
good just a little good that was a
really small class that I poured myself
at first
next the cost kids are so expensive swim
lessons there's new shoes every other
week their feet grow so fast I don't
understand how it's like hobbits they
just like take it take and take all your
money and then they don't even
appreciate it like my son it's all
organic I spend all this extra money
buying him organic food so I make him
his organic bread turkey sandwich he'll
ask for the crust to be cut off so the
other morning I cut the crust off then
all of a sudden he decided in that time
I was cutting the crust that he doesn't
want the crust cut off anymore
so I serve him the sandwich and he's
like oh my god mom meltdown flop on the
floor wiggle around so I take the crust
I'm like
having them like squeezing them trying
to get the mustard to like stick them
back on but no that's not going to do he
doesn't even want to see the crust
anymore it's too traumatizing for him so
I eat them because that's pretty much
lunch I have these days how dare you mom
for eating my crust I actually wanted it
all along
you can't win and finally why your child
is going to ask why - every mundane
little thing you say that grass is green
why because of chlorophyll
why I don't remember eighth grade
biology I it makes you realize how
little you know about the world but on
the other hand you have this opportunity
and this chance to make something
beautiful it's basically like learning
from your life and making something
better for somebody else I can't think
of something that holds any more meaning
than that all I can hope is that I don't
[ __ ] it up so that's all for now I have
about two sips left of this and that's
my cue to lay down melt into the couch
was a nice crappy TV show until next
time I'm Hannah your neighborhood wine
mom and I'll see you later
you will see me like this go
my mom never punished me for burping
that was like the one thing that she was
rude